okay so did you just a holdup now
someone hasn't said anything yet today
because it's three of you hands up it
could someone give me some examples of
whole numbers 42 the meaning of life
good choice okay Nolan 100 no yeah fine
fantastic let's see - yeah good let's
have one more okay perfect these are all
integers I'd like you to have a list of
examples by the way okay these are all
great their whole you can tell because
they're not divided up into any parts
okay it's a good list but not a complete
list these numbers are integers but when
they see a few important know for
instance I'm just thinking back to what
you did on Monday okay something like
say minus 3 or negative 3 you like
don't shout out yet just think about it
first
is it an integer if it is how could you
justify if it's not why not hmm
now I don't want you to raise your hands
just yet
I want you to write on your page maybe
at the top somewhere out of a way on the
side I want you to write down for
yourself
nothing person X you just shell do you
think just right for boss is -3 a whole
Lala and integer or not it is false it's
not and the only reason why I'm asking
right now it's just so you commit
something so when I asked you to put the
heads in a second you don't change I got
the EDS are wrong yes
I was totally saying
are you ready who'd written something
down okay isn't it into job okay hands
up if you said true yeah
heads up that's not bad but a lot of
people who you thought it wasn't that's
okay hands down
it is it it's a job now how can we say
it is well what kinds of things could we
divide up into to show it hmm what does
it mean that's a whole bottle yeah at
the back still a whole number it's just-
well okay I agree that's correct but
what does that even mean what is what
does it mean to be negative we're gonna
address that question in a second any
other suggestions
why could you justify that this is an
integer okay I'm gonna let that simmer
for a little while you'll have to get
used to this I will ask you questions a
lot and I won't yet tell you the answer
because I could tell you but then you
stop thinking about it once you have any
answer so when you don't have the answer
yet your brains still going okay
hold on to that thought doesn't I'm
gonna give you another number all of you
okay and I want you to write down the
same thing true or false do you think
there's number I'm about to write down
is it integer
zero naught easy to din to jump right to
lead down
you haven't think about it yourself if
you're on the French you're like I don't
really know and flip the coin make a
decision commit to something great thank
you
hopefully we have enough people have
points but it's does anyone either okay
all right so he's only good at this time
I'm gonna I'm gonna make it a little
more costly I want you to stand up
rather than from your hand up okay so we
count of three don't you stand up if you
think so John and I want you to stay
seated if you think it's not okay can't
three wait one two threes oh okay all
right excellent
now this is fantastic this is really
good because very evenly split okay I'm
gonna ask you just stay standing for a
second okay
people who is seated there's more of you
so you have more of an obligation can
you explain why you don't think it's an
integer value
sorry accommodated okay I'll take that
as a reason any other excavations talk
back
not a number I don't I'll get to that
I'm glad you mentioned it no value it's
not even really it's like less than 1 so
if one's like a hold and zero would be
so it's kind of like it's kind of like
nothing okay this is I'm interested by
this because it has something to do with
this doesn't whole division these kind
of money anyone but we've got one two
three four four and a half reasons any
one is just something different no it's
not integer as if it's a disease yeah
why not
okay stay seated and stay standing up
raise your hand if you said it wasn't a
teacher but you don't really know why
just your gut is like I had I've known
articulate reasons heads up it's okay
I'm just curious
okay thank you hands down I didn't give
you a sin of offense option so that's
okay to be there okay people standing up
I gave you a whole few minutes there to
think about
what your reasons are and you're
standing on your brave why do you think
it's an integer let's start with that
yeah
first let me say you can't always trust
dictionaries gotta be careful
Oh what was that uh wasn't a mass
dictionary but I'm just curious
was it just a regular dictionary just
now sir that one because it maths this
is why mathematics dictionaries exist
often things have very special meanings
sometimes very counterintuitive it
okay well we'll revisit this one okay
other other suggestions yeah that's true
yes okay so you're thinking about you
you thought about how much of examples
of things that were not integers zero
seems to be okay any other different
sorts of reasons
so you said three to ten so why is why
is it a problem if series of them are
why why is that a why cause I have this
number what's the problem with that I
think we were afraid of the place value
system right the place value system
needs zero yeah okay one more reason
anyone else have let's take that I'm
gonna push back on it though and not
just to uh sorry what's your name again
not just my theory on all of you I want
to ask the question what zero zero but
I'm asking not just about importance I
am asking about integers okay
he's one of us should do Heuer steady on
you take a seat okay remember who you
are
just just thinking it legs a break
basically okay and to those who are
standing actually the people who weren't
standing I want you to now reach over to
someone who was standing nearby you and
shake their hands and say
congratulations congratulations because
people who were standing up
you were right now zero isn't it now
hold on a second
this is not just a balance who's right
who's wrong okay there's something
interesting here I'm gonna go at these
because it's not it's just these wrong
but they're the way that they're not
important for us is is valuable
okay so let's the event it is their
value okay that's kinda true this was
the original onion by the way for what
zero should have been introduced into
our number system because it wasn't
always a part of it how could you have I
can have one cow I can have three cows I
can even understand I owe you three cows
I use them
they made yours no or whatever but it's
eerie colors you might as well say I
have zero you know asteroids or
something who cares if you have zeros
okay but the question we're asking is
about integers so it's really about
holes we come back to that the second is
it a number yeah it's not quite a number
the way other numbers are is it right
like what happens when you multiply by
zero or divide by zero or add zero it
certainly fits different rules and all
the rest of the numbers okay so I think
that one's that one's interesting
okay zero is special it's test the one
where true enough there are numbers that
are less than one and they are integers
so I think we're okay with that now this
one is really interesting
it can't be divided it can't be divided
recently my so did you see you again I
mention it because division and hold us
and very very linked ideas okay now if
it can't be divided if it can't be
divided that means it has half and you
can either say a two way so you can
either say that one pot full of nothing
or it has good pots zero like a nifty
seem like it's literally empty that's
what that's what a sea monster the fact
that it can't be divided it has no parts
means that if it's got their parts be
home isn't that was like divided its in
pieces so let's think of some numbers
that really aren't integers okay because
I think this might be a little bit
easier okay